so this right here is why Elon Musk is a
genius if you don't know Twitter blue is
your premium service it costs eight
dollars a month to be able to use but
elon's also been in a massive fight with
apple uh CEO Tim Cook over their fees
like he thinks it's ridiculous that
people have to pay 30 uh fee to Apple
for anything sold through the Apple
Store and people have been pissed for
years about this and nobody has done
anything about it except for just a
little bit of complaining
Elon joked about being able to build his
own phone company to rival apple he also
talked about maybe getting kicked out of
the Apple store which wouldn't be good
for Twitter or Elon because now he loses
a big user base and it's also not great
for Apple because they're already being
watched by the Monopoly Watch Dogs so
that doesn't help that they have so much
power so this right here is an amazing
Solutions like hey you're charging me
more I'm going to pass that on to the
users where it's eight dollars if you
buy to the web or eleven dollars if you
buy through the App Store he's Shifting
the blame to Apple away from himself and